We've got new details out
about the recent G7 meeting
in Canada,
when our so-called "allies"
tried to bully Trump
into signing
the summit communiqué,
which is French
for "dumb letter."
Check it.
Trump was sitting there
with his arms crossed.
He said, okay, he'll sign it.
And at that point, he stood up,
uh, he put his hand
in his pocket--
his suit jacket pocket--
and he took
two Starburst candies out,
threw them on the table,
and said to Merkel,
uh, "Here, Angela,
don't say
I never give you anything."
(chuckles):
Hoo-hoo-hoo.
You just got candy burnt,
Merkel.
This is why Trump's
a strong leader.
He's got brains, balls,
and a jacket full of candy.
Nothing weird about an old man
walking around,
handing out candy.
I imagine how happy the PR team
over at Starburst is right now,
frantically calling
the Tic Tac people on the phone
and screaming, "What the (bleep)
do we do now?!"
Which reminds me, libs,
you say
Trump doesn't respect women.
What do you call giving the most
powerful woman in the world
two warm pocket Starbursts?
That's respect.
And, sure,
it was the yellow ones,
but the flavors
of Starburst Superfruit
pack a super intense,
bodacious punch.
(chuckles)
(bell ringing)
Tim Baltz, I turn to you!
(cheering and applause)
How boss
was Trump's
Starburst power play?
Jordan, I know this seems like
the funniest thing to happen
at a G7 meeting
since Silvio Berlusconi
Smirnoff Iced Tony Blair.
But I am not laughing.
Because this proves once again
that America
is the world's candy man.
Everybody's just dying to get
on America's sweet,
sweet candy teat.
Well, here you go,
you globalist parasites.
Take our candy,
'cause we're the candy man!
All they do is take, take, take!
First, you're giving Starbursts
to the Germans.
Then, the next thing you know,
you're throwing Necco Wafers
at all the Canadians!
Almond Joy at the Frenchies!
And pretty soon,
you're delicately placing
soggy Junior Mints into
the mouth of every Irishman,
your fingers touching
their thin, wet lips
and thick, dry tongues.
-So much grosser
than I thought it'd be. -Yeah.
Exactly, Jordan.
My fingers are wet
from your mouth.
But that's life when you're
the world's candy man.
People always ringing
my doorbell,
thrusting a bag in my face,
demanding a treat.
Children, even.
I'd say mostly children.
And they're always dressed up
as my favorite movie characters,
like Batman or Moana. Why?
Because they're too afraid
to confront the candy man.
Well, here's your candy,
you grubby little Spider-Men!
T-Tim, I think
you're talking about Halloween.
Well, every day's Halloween
when you're the candy man!
People just want
to suck you dry!
Oh, oh, Daddy Landlord
wants his rent check.
Sorry! I only pay in candy!
Great, the IRS wants back taxes.
Fine! Fund your abortions
with my candy!
Meanwhile, the scrooges down
at the candy store are all,
"You can't pay for candy
with more candy."
Oh, yeah?! Watch me, candy man!
'Cause you're dealing
with the candy man!
Where did you get
all that candy?!
A candy truck tipped over
in front of my house.
Christmas for the candy man!
Which, uh, by the way,
Jordan, reminds me...
(chuckles)
don't say I, uh,
never gave you anything.
Tim Baltz, the candy man.